free il y à 25 ans nelson mendela
devenait le premier président noir de
l'afrique du sud les files s'allongent
et sur des kilomètres tous les noirs
voulaient voter pour élire le congrès
national africain le parti qui avait
combattu et vaincu le régime raciste de
l'apartheid
cet héritage permet à l'indicé de se
maintenir au pouvoir depuis 25 ans une
longévité problématique selon ce
politologue qui vient de l'afrique du
sud et la corruption qui s'est répandue
pendant le mandat de l'ancien président
monsieur jacob zuma qui a vraiment
introduit un niveau de corruption
hallucinant au pays ça coûtait exception
ma chère on estime 25 milliards de
dollars était perdu dans le budget de
l'état chaque année
celui qui a succédé à jacob zuma à la
tête du parti et du pays
remettre de combattre la corruption et
de congédier ses collègues corrompus
[Musique]
mais des millions de ceux d'afrique et
n'y croit plus la fin de l'apartheid n'a
rien changé pour la très grande majorité
des noirs du pays
plus que deux tiers des noix vit dans la
pauvreté absolue et uniquement 1% des
bla on peut dire également que c'est le
pays le plus inégal au monde
les jeunes nés après l'apartheid baptisé
la génération bons fruits boules
massivement les urnes
plus du quart ne se sont pas inscrits
même si cela aurait été le premier vote
de leur vie a rien comme quoi internet
je ne crois pas que j'aurais voté 17
étudiants aucun parti ne me représente
ce jeune architecte sans emploi n'a pas
voté il n'y a pas que les jeunes qui
sont désillusionnés bien des militants
historiques de l'insee ont rejoint les
combattants de la liberté un parti qui
promet de redonner au noir les terres
agricoles qui appartiennent encore
largement aux blancs oui acabit possible
de piloter pour nous allons nous joindre
aux fastes indique-t-il et si vous ne
nous accepte et pas à la table a dit ne
nous briseront la table une approche
radicale qui plaît au plus frustrés qui
se sentent trahis par les promesses non
tenues de la nc
cet artiste vit avec d'autres gens à
faible revenu sur un terrain acheté par
le parti de julius malema baptisé la
valise du julius
c'est le seul parti dit il qui nous
donnent des terrains qui se bat pour
nous mais la majorité des sud-africains
noirs malgré les souffrances et les
désillusions sont encore incapables de
voter pour un autre parti que celui de
nelson mandela le plus important aux
comptes m c'est le nombre de sièges avec
lequel il termine
ça lui permettra de dire vous voyez que
malgré toutes les désillusions on a
quand même gardé une position importante
ça lui permettra de vraiment faire le
ménage au sein de l'unss et ce qui est
essentiel c'est le seul suspense de
cette élection
les appuis à la nc vont-ils chuté en
deçà de 60%
si c'est le cas l'héritier de mandela
aura beaucoup de difficulté à
transformer un parti corrompu ce filon
gloire radio canada montréal